the plant pregnancy project illustrates
the impact humans have on plants by
encouraging them to care for plants as
lovingly as pets or babies and tandem is
a water saving concept for public men's
rooms where a sink is combined with a
urinal Vsauce Kevin here this is mind
blow Unocal allows a user to buy things
with their face the world's first facial
recognition payment system simply
requires the customer to confirm their
purchase by clicking ok on a tablet the
system recognizes your face and accesses
your information from its database and
cuts down transaction time to less than
5 seconds they're preparing to test the
system in Helsinki and in case you're
wondering about differentiating
identical twins they're going to need to
enter a pin password the ih2 Azura hand
is the first robotic hand on the market
that is human sized and able to
replicate real human hand functions at
human-like speeds created by italian
based company priscilly a-- it can grasp
different items at different weights
with both power and precision as well as
advanced digit manipulation and sensing
abilities and its uses range from
prosthetics to humanoid robotics and
various research applications akira
miyawaki is creating forests to reduce
tsunami damage the 1,000 year key ball
naka project features dense deep-rooted
trees planted in large mounds created by
using debris from previous tsunami
destruction and then locating these
along the shores in Japan so that they
can greatly reduce the negative impact
of future tsunamis by reducing the
energy potential of the way this app
lets you know in real time which
restaurants have available seating the
system collects data throughout the
dining experience from sitting and
ordering to paying the bill
by working with the restaurants
point-of-sale system giving you
real-time exact updates depending on the
actual situations happening inside the
restaurant which allows users and Japan
the ability to choose a different
restaurant based on seating availability
here's a design for the fold-out solar
charger for the Volvo v60 plug-in hi
so yeah boxed is furniture in a suitcase
the adaptable furniture designed by
Tyrone Stoddard has the ability to be a
coffee table a desk two stools and a
lamp it can then all be broken down and
put back into its case to be carried off
to a new location by B Rio is a
touchscreen that senses fingerprints
freeing users from having to use any
other type of identification the
fiber-optic plate the screen uses gives
it the ability to both display images
and sense fingerprints at the same time
applications for this could be in the
workplace where based on your
fingerprints the system would only allow
you to access data that you're giving
clearance for bones of a new dinosaur
were found in Utah and they kind of look
like a cow and a triceratops had a baby
the Medi robot created by the University
of Calgary was made to soothe children
getting vaccines the robot plays with
the kids high-fives them and teaches
them relaxation techniques for before
during and after their shots and
apparently he also does Taichi arrow is
a concrete recycling robot that
disassembles concrete structures using
water jets to crack the surface of the
concrete and then suck up the debris the
arrow makes the destruction of concrete
cleaner and more effective because
previous systems created huge dusty
mounds of concrete and metal to be
sorted through it also saves a lot of
water by recycling it back through
itself finally here's a female tung
Guerra frog attracted to a potential
mate that's actually a robotic version
of her male counterpart I'm gonna leave
you with a gymnastic robot landing a
quadruple backflip off a bar and as
always thanks for watching